now there's been a shooting in the u.s
city of indianapolis
local media say multiple people have
been taken to hospitals in the area
police were called to respond to reports
of shots fired at a fedex facility on
the southwest side of the city near
indianapolis international airport now
police have confirmed that the gunman is
dead and say they do not believe the
general public
is in immediate danger
after a preliminary search of the
grounds inside and out
we have located eight people at the
scene
with injuries consistent to gunshot
wounds
those eight were pronounced deceased
here at the scene
it is very heartbreaking and you know
indianapolis metropolitan police
department the officers responded they
came in they went in and they did their
job
and a lot of them are trying to face
this because this is a site that no one
should ever have to see
we can get the latest on the story now
with senior reporter for business
insider anya kane as she is in
indianapolis and
at the scene at that fedex facility anya
thanks so much for joining us
as we said you are there tell us what
you're hearing and seeing on what has
happened
absolutely thanks for having me um yeah
i'm standing outside of the fedex
facility in south
on the southwest side of indianapolis um
all is quiet here right now although
you can still see some of the police
lights in the background going off
um there's not much to update you on at
this point
it seems like there's been media
gathering
all night there was a brief presser that
happened shortly before i arrived here
where
indianapolis police confirmed that the
gunman was dead
and did not really share many other
details at this point i can say that i
observed
a bus and a caravan of cars
um being escorted by police cars leaving
this area
so it's possible that that could have
the family members of potential victims
or even witnesses
um departing for an unknown location
yeah anya we we are seeing some reports
from the associated press that
apparently
up to eight people have been shot dead
can you tell us more about
who might be injured and what more
police are saying about that
absolutely i'm i actually just got off
the phone with uh
state police uh they weren't really able
to clarify about
a number of casualties or number of
injuries at this point
i've seen unconfirmed reports that it
could be up to 60 injured
but at this point i have no verification
on that
we do know that this is a very large
facility
and police appear to still be going
through it so it's possible that there
could be
casualties or injuries that we don't
know about yet just because police still
have to
secure the scene and police still have
to go through and make sure everyone's
out of this facility
and anya you know police as you said
have said the gunman is dead is there
any indication i know it's very early
but any indication what
the motive might have been
yeah as you as you mentioned it's very
early i mean it's hard to but
with something like this it's
unfortunately so common in the united
states
you know and the motive is often
something that we want to know
early on um haven't heard anything on
that
seems like police are really trying to
hold back on those details until they
really are able to confirm them and nail
them down so
we're still at such an early part of the
investigation
no whispers about a motive quite yet
unfortunately
all right we'll leave it there a senior
reporter for business insider anya kane
at the scene there at that fedex
facility in indianapolis
thank you so much for bringing us up to
date
thanks so much